ist es in 60 fps schien es als würde ich
besser aus der internen schreiben jetzt
das wird knapp das will club savosa
skills und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft und das ist keine
folge wie jeder andere denn heute
spielen wir zum allerersten mal mit 60
fps bzw
wir nehmen mit 60 fps auf und bespielt
zum ersten mal seit einer langen langen
zeit wieder mal in time und ich glaube
ich muss die sound mit michael kaiser
mache mache ich sofort leute lasst mich
nur kurz hier mal bisschen checken wie
die lage ist ich habe da hinten weiß
dass ich genug bin der vermittler
gewissen tagen habe ich gefühlt oder
weißwürste stand bei den richterstand
sich das warten war okay da kann ich
nichts kaufen
ich glaube da kann ich das kaufen oh
jetzt wirds eng
jetzt bitte nicht gerade jetzt irgendwie
wissen käse machen hier eher ungünstig
ok damit zumindest ein bisschen stoff
ich mache dich sonst leider jolo auf 10%
denn ihr wisst in time ist immer so
wissen laut nice price or is on my side
resort hat eine heiterkeit verschwunden
ist er verschwunden ich glaube kann ich
sonst noch ein bisschen langsamer machen
lassen sie sounds leiser machen leute
was haltet ihr davon schreibt in die
kommentare
ich hoffe wir einfach dass der
spielmodus nicht ab kratzt bitte opengl
bitte man ich sollte ich schauspieler
werden ohne wird jedes mal wenn ich so
tun als wäre ich wirklich traurig kommt
mir echt drehen
ich würde so gerne sieht gerade aber
seine augen meine haare schneiden wie
geil ab ist freue mich sehr wenn diese
ab stehen sich aus wie eine palme ich
sehe ich aus wie eine palme man sowieso
richtiger congo after es muss auch nicht
sein dass ich habe heute sehr fertig
gemacht
wir haben von looz plan erfahren leute
solche von nutzt klare zählen
soll ich okay aber jetzt hört zu ok blut
plan ist es die welt zu infizieren
wie mit einem medium was er sich schon
ausgedacht hat ich kann euch das jetzt
nicht sagen weil er mich sonst erwischt
nachts aber höher zu leute passt auf
lutz will die welt mit seiner pace
sprache und seinen peace gegangen von
infizieren wenn ihr in die lage kommt
jürgen boss von loeb neue ist dankeschön
nwdr in die hand bekommen übrigens ein
videodreh gecrasht dann sei vorsichtig
und springt mit mir in anderen spielen
produzieren nun räumte da sind wir
wieder bespielen es runde minecraft
flash und ich sag's dir noch einmal los
ich hab dich enttarnt jetzt ist es
offiziell informiert wir werden bald
auch dort informieren
von deinem händler dreckigen plan die
leute kaputt zu machen mit deinen
gedanken wo dank um mit meinem banken
gut das wird nicht funktionieren los du
scheiß pizza wir haben dich eher
bestärkt jetzt bist nicht mal undercover
cover luanda terni das ist weißt du
bescheid und leute habt ihr schon eine
idee wie lou thesz gemacht haben könnte
was es planung für den hinterhältigen
attentat von history of germany schreibt
in die kommentare
wie hat lutz dass es geplant überlegt
euch wie könnte er ganz ganz viele leute
mit seinen hits gedanken infizieren
überlegt es euch und schreibt schreibt
es in die kommentare
als würdet ihr meinen namen in die
kommentare schreiben aber schreibt nicht
mehr namen in die kommentare
sondern eine überlegung
sieht man jetzt kann ich es wieder nicht
vergessen was ist spring r wie eine
fluglinie die trampoline transportiert
ohne witz kommen wir können es schaffen
hier raus ja und jetzt sagt neißer jetzt
einfach mal hier genau jobs schon sehr
schön so beschaffen ist jetzt als würden
wir mich würden wir mich erzeugen
zusammen wir schaffen ist
jetzt gibt es gibt ganz als würde ich
meinem kollegen g nur ein bisschen als
abdrücken gibt
wir setzen ein baum läuft wir haben
jetzt den letzten checkpoint vor letzten
checkpoint glaube ich wie viele
checkpoints gibt es auf der map fliegt
vielleicht 443 ich glaube es gibt vier
und dann noch das ziel und da vorne ist
jetzt der vierte
jetzt können wir nicht ins ziel mein
stil mag diesen parcours habe ich
richtig respekt man vor dem habe ich
richtig doll respekt weil ich gerne mal
mein halbes leben verbringen bis ich da
irgendwann ziel ankomme manchmal schaue
ich nicht mal warum war ich nicht
jump'n'run bett kempen rp vor dem wird
es jetzt hier nach wieder richtig wusste
ich dann mal wieder eine rote ampel zu
spielen weil ich hab' ich hatte es ja
meinem stream das problem
ich weiß nicht wer von euch dabei war
könnte man die kommentare schreiben das
problem das wir dass wir
jump league gespielt hatten ich rede
jetzt einfach mal von mir selbst in der
pluralistischen ordnung dass wir ich
gespielt habe und danach minecraft flash
so und das ist an sich kein problem man
muss jetzt vielleicht ein gewinner denkt
okay wer das spiel modus und da kommt
man so langsam rein
man denkt sich ok ich muss doch nicht so
behindert was war das treffen gewimmel
egal ich gehen hoch und dann steht man
ein paar runden flash und gewöhnt sich
so dass an hier so mega früh ab springen
wenn man die ganzen herunterfällt
ja und dann spielt man wieder eine runde
jump league und dann geht's einfach
bergab und dann leidet man weil man
nachdem man minecraft fleisch für eine
weile gespielter job spielt dann kann
man nichts mehr
nicht mal die einfachsten sprünge das
ist so lächerlich
es ist wirklich so lächerlich und
weniger das gleiche in der aufnahme ich
weiß nicht wie die folge heißt ich
glaube seine cracks zu runde immer
irgendwas genannt irgendwie so dass
genannt und leute jetzt müssen wir uns
wieder konzentrieren ich regiere denn
die richtige sprache in die wichtige
sprache über ok denn jetzt während wir
zum ersten mal versuchen eine runde in
60 apps zu beenden schreibt mal auch
bitte gerne mal in die kommentare wie
ihr es findet in 60 fps ist es in 60 fps
schien es als würde ich besser außer
internet schreibt jetzt rein wir schauen
jetzt 60 das ist glaub das wird das wird
knapp
junge ich weiß nicht wie ich den sprung
schaffen
jedes mal denke ich dass ich da
irgendwie auf sony pad drauf klatsche
aber irgendwie klappt trotzdem die junge
holz kümmert findet finnischen ex- web
tv anschauen was vielleicht passiert und
er liebte die runde und zwar dass ich
gewinne junge leute aber wie gesagt auch
wenn wir gewonnen haben lasst euch nicht
allen leuten sedlitz mit beiden augen
und lasst euch nicht von wem
pitts gedanken infizieren okay j&j wir
werden uns noch mal zusammensetzen und
überlegen was wir machen kann
lars cohrs jetzt leicht nach oben wir
sehen uns in diesem video keystone
macht's gut und